diese knusprig frittierten reispächen
sollte es eigentlich an jeder Ecke geben
wir machen
aranchine am liebsten mache ich
aranchine wenn ich eh schon Risotto
gekocht habe dann lasse ich es einmal
Auskühlen auf so einem Tablett wie
diesem hier und dann ist es wirklich ein
Kinderspiel wie man das Risotto kocht
habe ich euch schon im letzten Video
gezeigt dann portioniere ich den
erkalteten Reis er muss wirklich schön
kalt sein dann funktioniert das am
besten mit blockscraper natürlich am
besten zu portionieren aranchine sind
einfach ein Traum einfach Käse in die
Mitte und wir machen unsere aranina zu
die klebt schon wunderschön dann einfach
in pancomml von allen Seiten bedecken
schon ist sie fertig für die Friteuse
das mache ich jetzt mit allen das
Tablett ist leer die aranchine sind
geformt schon schön mit penco bedeckt
man sieht auf jeden Fall das ist
Handarbeit ich Form die alle noch mal
kurz nach damit die eine richtig schöne
runde Form haben bevor ich sie dann auch
in die Friteuse gebe und wenn diese
goldbraune Farbe erreicht ist sind wir
fertig jetzt platzieren wir unsere
aranina einfach auf einem Teller
wunderschön diese schöne goldbraune
frittierte Farbe wow dann toppen wir mit
ein bisschen Parmesan und ein paar
Kräutern fürs Auge